I told Sam about this but it bears
repeating I was having a conversation
with someone as an executive at YouTube
and I asked them why someone got a
Community Guidelines strike on their
account because they posted up a video
on their playlist that they enjoyed of
Sam Harris
and Douglas Murray engaged in a
conversation I go why would that get you
a Community Guidelines strike and this
woman said because it's hate speech I
got a problem with the last and sorry
apparently Douglas Murray caused me
problems somebody worked yes she was a
big executive equate YouTube she said
it's hate speech and I told her I go did
you listen to it I go you didn't listen
to it I got this is stunning that you
would just say it's hate speech then you
just be so dismissive of it so quickly
and she talked to me as if I was her
employee like I was not allowed to
question her and she was just gonna say
what she said and I was gonna shut up
and it was a fascinating conversation no
no no why on vacation no but it was I I
did a podcast with Douglas and
apparently it got flagged someone else
put it up on their account and I got
flagged as hates patron strikes you can
get your account removed so I've got a
phrase for this and I've been I've been
rallying for it on on social media for a
couple of months now and I call it a
digital blind spot there's a cultural
bias on social media where because of
and it's intellectually lazy because
because social media is essentially a
Californian invention right and we're in
the home state of where most of this
came from
it's got a very Californian based
worldview which cares a lot about white
supremacy and doesn't care about many
other forms of bigotry they exist out
there in the rest of the world which by
the way is the majority of the world so
on Twitter right now of course there's
my lien appleís has been banned
Tommy Robinson has been banned as in
taken off now Twitter's a private
company Robinson he's the former leader
of the British English Defence League
which was at one time Europe's largest
anti Muslim Street protest group I
helped him leave that organisation he's
still what many views I completely
disagree with but nevertheless he
doesn't support or nor advocate for
terrorism
why was he removed well so Twitter
Twitter is a private company it can
choose to remove whoever it wants for
whatever reason and we will judge it for
its inconsistencies but he was
ostensibly removed for hey
speech as was milo unitless now the
point being that still till this day and
before people misquote me and completely
say that i'm now defending hate speech
and and it's and their right to speak
with hateful views on twitter this is my
actual point that till this day did you
know that hezbollah which is a known and
recognized terrorist organization
so forget hate speech for a moment a
terrorist organization that believes in
actually killing civilians and hamas a
known and recognized terrorist
organization that believes in bombing
babies on buses as a form of resistance
they still have accounts on twitter and
my point is is that this is the this is
the blind spot you know that and i've
flag twitter about this on many an
occasion this is the cultural blind spot
this is the digital blind spot that the
dude sitting in california in wherever
who is monitoring this stuff and it's
probably more than one person they don't
give a [ __ ] that there's some brown
person in the gaza strip that believes
it's okay to kill jewish babies they
don't give a [ __ ] because it's a brown
person saying it in the name of islam
what they care about is a non-violent
yet says stupid things guy because he's
white called Tommy Robinson in England
or Milo u Annapolis saying stuff that
they obviously that touches their
sensitivities and it's so intellectually
lazy to flag that immediately and to bar
it from social media because you're
comfortable with it you recognize white
supremacy it doesn't take any effort to
recognize it you don't have to invest in
studying this stuff to know what white
supremacy is it takes a bit of effort to
study brown people's ideas that you're
unfamiliar with and recognize here's a
terrorist organization that's freely
operating on social media I know
specifically on Twitter
I've actually pulled up their handles I
think one of the concerns that Twitter
has and I think this is a valid concern
is that when you have people there
saying hateful things and you have
people that are saying whether it's
white supremacy or whatever even if it's
stupid yeah the problem is there's a
rallying cry of trolls that follow
behind them and it builds up momentum
and it gets pretty stunning and that was
what was happening with Milo and by
silencing Milo off Twitter they
have essentially removed him from the
public discourse you don't hear about
him what's right because of this because
of these things but imagine what that
does in Arabic with the terror scripts
yes but there's there everything you've
just said by the way I agree with and
multiply that for groups that have
infrastructure in multiple countries
with actual organizational hierarchies
and planned means of distributing their
ideas across entire populations
physically fighting in wars right now
such as Hezbollah in Syria killing Sunni
Muslim rebels you know and so imagine
that and the and the way you're able to
rally a mob in Pakistan on blasphemy as
an example all it takes for some person
on social media to accuse another person
or blasphemy and they're probably gonna
get killed the very next day where and
it happens all the time but but because
these californian based social media
companies are unaware of of the of the
cultural implications of those sorts of
organizations and groups and listed
terrorist groups mind you they are this
completely no no barring on any of their
activity there's also the same thing
that you have with YouTube and with a
lot of these other social media
organizations and companies is they
don't have to respond or give you any
reasons they can say it violates our
Terms but what are those terms those
terms aren't even listed it would be
vague like no hate speech okay well
what's hate speech like what what do you
say like what is what are you what is
your clear policy what are your
guidelines
how does someone avoid violating your
guidelines they don't say and how is the
president the United States not of non
violating those yeah well the
monetization is another way that they do
it they'll remove the ability to put
advertising on a conversation that they
don't like and it doesn't have to be
like my conversation with Douglas Murray
was D monster I D without any
explanation none zero then we have it
Douglas is he's he's clearly flat on
there yeah but if you listen to our acts
the actual context of our conversation
there's nothing even remotely remotely
hateful about it yeah yeah I mean these
are private companies they've got the
right to to choose whatever policy the
only thing I would expect from a private
company is show a consistent policy
towards these things you know if you
don't like hate speech then brown band
brown people who are also advocating
more than just the hate speech but
actually preaching violent terrorism
right
yeah it's a strange time for this man
because it's it's also a time where it's
you can communicate so instantaneously
it's fantastic in that regard you can
get ideas out so quickly but these hubs
of information like where the
information gets distributed are they're
controlled by people that I don't think
ever knew that they were gonna have this
sort of responsibility I don't think I
think you're seeing that with Zuckerberg
and these trials or the the the the
speeches that he's given in front of
Congress like when you see him on
television talking about it you get the
sense that this is a guy that never
prepared for this had no idea this is
going to happen and then all of a sudden
from this simple social media platform
there was supposed to be friends sharing
photos and just talking about girls ya
know ya put women there's a lot of that
you know but I mean - and what was
Twitter I mean Twitter was essentially
just you know I mean you remember the
old days at Twitter it would be you
would use your name it like is doing
this like Sam understand Harris like Sam
Harris is at the movies you would say
that almost if you were in a third
person that was the original form that
people would use Twitter come after that
yeah it was weird
it was a weird way of talking and then
people started just writing what they
thought yeah and it just became and then
became ideology and then it became
sharing links sharing links and
interesting articles is a big part of it
but to me that's the only good part of
it now like I got like a I've just
discovered that and that was most of my
attachment to it I mean I I genuinely
use it to as a curated news because I
follow interesting people they say they
tweet interesting stuff and I and I
consumed it that way but noticing what's
coming back at me in the at mansion so I
put something out you know with my
podcast and then I look to see how it's
being received on Twitter and I don't
tend to do that in other forums I don't
really look at facebook comments much I
don't look at YouTube on YouTube it's
just a cesspool right I mean so so even
if therefore you that the comments are
horrible on YouTube I have
yeah nastiness started on the youtube
comment France it's and